now we're out of in this country baby
formula
perfect just
just
just when the supreme court comes up
with the formula for more
babies oh yes
oh yes ladies you're an american now not
only do we make you carry the baby to
term now we're gonna make you breastfeed
the little thing okay
never
everybody wants to know
why are we out of the you know
baby formula well a few issues supply
chain issues which are real
contamination that happened in a couple
of places that's real and of course nick
cannon
[Applause]
but you know i mean inflation is that
not what is on everybody's mind that's
that's like the subject of the day
everywhere prices are up 11 that's a
really big jump we haven't had that in
decades and decades i'll say this for
donald trump when he was president
america felt cheap
[Applause]
but
gas
the gasoline whoa that has people very
upset i was balleting like
i was
valeting my car the other day and the
valet guy said pull it up a little i
said i can't afford it
you